foreign
everybody's freaking out about the
latest round of negative news I'm not
freaked out just for the right I know
you aren't but we'll tell people why
okay so the The Source here we want to
just give a brief amount of perspective
because the news exists to freak us out
Scaris they want Pearl clutching hand
ringing it makes for good ratings George
and then they can sell those ads for a
little bit more money
so the latest is freaking people out
about our financial future specifically
the dollar all right so you've got you
know Putin uh Vladimir uh Vladimir Putin
Mr Russia over there and you got Xi
Jinping who is the Chinese premiere and
now they're hanging out three-day Summit
they're in cahoots George I don't like
it I don't like it either and so you got
Putin and jijing hanging out and they're
talking about an alliance to threaten
the U.S dollar and you want the direct
quote from Putin on this anytime we can
hear from Putin I like to hear from you
I'm tempted to try my Russian accent but
I think I will offend all people groups
in doing so well if you died seriously
this evening we will know why okay I so
badly want to do it I'm so nice just do
it it's an entertainment favor of using
the Chinese Yuan for settlements between
Russia and the countries of Asia Africa
and Latin America what do you he's watch
too many James Bond movies but I will
apply it again that's pretty good so
there's the quote he's saying uh
basically they want to switch from the
dominant dollar oh sure and move to the
Chinese Yuan yeah so which could hurt
America obviously so you've got two
schools of thought when you see news
like this right you can go out on the
internet and you can see a a whole line
of Articles and a opinion saying this is
really scary they're going to collude
They're Gonna Knock the dollar out and
they're going to take all of our savings
is this going to be an absolute disaster
and then on the other side you got just
as many experts and economists and
people going you know what if that were
to happen it would take a very very long
time China can't do it they won't do it
because they own most of our debt which
that part is true so the point we're
making here is we're not taking a
position on one way the other and we're
certainly not going to predict doomsday
okay what we are going to say is
you can control certain things and you
not having debt let's start there George
is a good thing oh absolutely so let's
talk about the consequences if this ever
were to happen which by the way we've
got an MSN piece here saying Plans by
Russia and China to challenge the Dollar
on the world stage are going nowhere
experts say Russia's fragile economy and
China's capital controls make both of
their currencies less appealing if that
gives you any peace right now let's talk
about some of the consequences if the US
were to lose its World Reserve currency
status so firstly the value of the
dollar would likely decrease which leads
to higher inflation nobody wants that
and even higher interest rates right now
here's the interesting part if you get
out of debt and you no longer need to
borrow money interest rates don't affect
you as much do they right so that's why
you're saying get out of debt yeah and I
do want to point out though George
because this is real if the dollar
uh were to be devalued because it was no
longer the reserve currency your dollars
would become pennies now that is a real
now again whether or not this happens or
not but it's not just the interest rates
available it's the value of your money
would decrease it's now 38 to get a
gallon of milk that's a scary scenario
that's exactly that's real terms right
there where everything well you think
inflation is high now okay so you know
this is a tenuous idea what could happen
could really freak you out oh absolutely
so again back to the way we teach in our
lifestyle right so if you've learned to
control your expenses uh you know but
this is by the way George you got to be
careful here I got to bring this up this
is the kind of stuff that Doom prep
Doomsday Preppers they really jump on
they're like you gotta have 400 cans of
green beans you gotta and you gotta
invest go invest in silver and gold all
day long but here's what I tell you that
advice I'm glad you brought that up the
silver and gold are tied to the dollar
so you don't it's not like you just skip
the whole all of the dollar crashes I
got a bunch of gold in their Hills you
know that doesn't work it's tied to the
dollar and so
um this is the type of thing where
there's just there's only so much you
can control and you not having any debt
you're not relying on the federal
government to bail you out it's a good
position to take oh absolutely and uh
the The Washington Post article goes on
to say America's politicians have gotten
used to spending seemingly without any
concerns about deficits and that is
another piece of this puzzle is
America's Got to get on the debt
snowball they really do smallest to
largest let's go now you know what I'm
glad you bring this up because this is
by the way this is both sides of the
aisle here I want to be an equal
opportunity offender what can the
average person do about the potential
devalue of the dollar
I don't mean to be cliche but it's only
take care of your house no no you vote
you vote men and women in there who will
get you know what I'm gonna run on
eliminate the national debt
I mean forget the rest of politics has
anyone ever even attempted let's just
imagine for a second if the American
people a huge of the American people
said all right they're going to run on
one issue alone forget about all the
other issues that are important to you
boy I just offended a bunch of people I
just said what if
what if we had a Congress that said
we're up there to actually kill the debt
we're going to pay the debt down and
America is going to be debt free for
some of you who think this is a
Preposterous idea many states in this
country haven't have a constitutional
amendment where they must balance their
budget
so it is doable there are state
governments in the United States right
now by law they must balance their
budget George which means
they don't have debt they got to balance
it it can be done I like this plan a lot
Ken and if you're running you've got I'm
not but I will tell you there's one guy
I know that if we stuck him in a room
full of people for 30 days I promise you
Dave could get a budget together
Dave Ramsey could put a budget together
that would balance the budget I'm here
for that I think America's cheering you
on right now no no I mean he's not
running but what if we took Dave up
there we made everybody get in the room
they couldn't leave until they agreed to
the budget he came up with I would I
would turn on C-Span to watch that could
you see Dave going to DC James with this
quickie budget for him all right America
we're going to do the quickie budget
here and then we're going to work
through this in 90 days we're using
every dollar we're gonna get the federal
budget balance I don't that's an insane
asylum for Dave to have to be in that
room with those people for 30 days I
don't know if he'd survive yeah he would
because no one else could talk he'd love
it he would just tell him how it's going
to be give Dave the mic only his mics
he's got scissors he's got the chain
he's got everything his all his props
here's what we're doing we're not
leaving until we balance the budget so
he could pay off the federal debt it's
the world's greatest debt snowball I
love it well hey I'm sleeping easy at
night I'm not freaked out about this you
shouldn't be either focus on what you
can control which is your life you more
money your house
it's that simple